Maserati has finally debuted its SUV the
76 thousand dollar levante this is the
first SUV from the Italian brand and
it's made to go up against new SUVs from
the likes of Bentley Jaguar and Porsche
it takes its name from a famous
mediterranean wind and maserati is
hoping it'd blow some new life into the
102 year old brand it'll take some doing
to beat the excellent cayenne and the
posh bent a gap but levante does come
with a distinctive look and feel the v6
430 horsepower car comes with a twin
turbo gasoline engine or a 275
horsepower turbo diesel engine it has an
8-speed automatic transmission on
all-wheel drive and it'll hit 60 miles
per hour in 5.2 seconds even better it
comes with full off-road capability not
that you'll actually use it and the
lowest center of gravity in its class
which is all the better for nimble
handling around corners there are five
different levels of ground clearance on
this SUV plus an extra one for parking
from the outside it looks surprisingly
not bad there are three iconic air vents
on the front the trapezoidal c-pillar
with the Maserati logo on the side and
the large frameless door windows the
back window is tapered and streamlined
through the entire rear on the inside
maserati has included hand wrapped
leather and one hundred percent zegna
silk trim plus enough seating and rear
room for five adults it looks and feels
just like what you'd expect from the
Maserati family want one you've got some
time the Levante goes on sale in europe
in may and in September in North America